what's the most important thing Emma I'm
gonna ask you first what's the most
important lesson you think about
motherhood that you learned from your
mother um I remember when both my kids
were young I remember mom specifically
saying to me you know just just be
patient because just when you get to
that moment where you think I am NOT
going to be able to survive another
sleepless night or I'm not going to be
able to survive this particular
developmental stage just when you think
you can't go another day it will change
and move on to the next thing and it
always did she was so right about that
and always they were out of it and on to
the next thing you know oh well Jolie
and we learned a lot from our kids - I
know I do even from my 45min always and
they fill all the gaps that didn't make
sense when you were a kid didn't they
wow that's a really great way to put it
I've never thought of it that way well
what's a lesson that you feel like
you've learned from Emma so many things
I mean more love than you can imagine I
mean I love my kids and I didn't
particularly when I was pregnant things
I didn't think of that I loved kids that
much it's a great gift in every way I
feel like I'm the same way I was if my
mom is still surprised that I'm married
with children Kelly you have to mention
the other three and what their names are
please oh yes oh I will totally do that
I have it right here and you know what
that's actually important to me and I
have it right here
you don't remember their names written
down or something no you were kids Kelly
your kids oh I thought you were too much
yours I was like no no no you oh no I
was like I was like I was
to tell you it's actually really
important for me that every time I do an
interview everybody always says oh you
have two children and I'm like no we
have four I've put in their lives for
eight years and we're blended so we as
Savannah's are 18 year old she's
actually an equestrian she does eventing
and she's a maid she's actually number
one in her division in the country so
she's amazing huh and then we have our
thirteen-year-old said he's awesome he's
our little gamer and he like does 3d
Sting's needing him he just creates he's
a really creative kid and he's actually
been my teleprompter guy for this whole
pandemic haha she like Sam is here
helping me working Sam and I work except
James as well those are the tiny ones
and they're driving me nuts so I could
use that patience talk right now but I
was gonna say I'm like you though I
didn't want kids I didn't think I'd ever
have kids and then once you do you're
right Julie like what you do it teaches
you an amazing amount of selflessness
you know I didn't realize how selfish I
was and I knew a little scream of love
that comes up and out of you I mean I
not I now know why people say I you know
get in front of a machine gun if it
saved my kids and I'm worried I don't do
anything for my kids yeah no I I am
definitely bad and we do learn for them
every day it's funny you learn I think
more about yourself and how you act
around them and you're like when I can
maybe work on that subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going